Bà, nếu xa all tình đến đây, cần nếu đã đưa vào khai thác, bằng yên và trong 4 làm kilomét đường bộ cá tóc,
tuy nhiên có khoảng 2,5% lệ 1 kilomét đường cá tóc,
đang khai thác theo quý mồ phân kỳ.
Trong đào, cóo xấu trong 5,5% đường cá tóc hai lần xe,
2,5% mộ mi tám kilomét đường cá tóc 1 lần xe,
chưa bà đam cuối chuẩn kiện thoát cuối xe về đường bộ cá tóc.
Tìm mạnh quyết cơ mất ăn thần xo thông, uống táng xo thông.
Bà ý việc nghiên cứu đầu tư nâng các khoảng thiện các tối nương bộ cá tóc,
đã đầu tư theo quý mồ phân kỳ là cình thiết.
Được lãnh đạo chính phủ chỉ đạo tư nghiệm kỳ trước,
giờ đó, phó thu tử tử tử trực yêu cầu bộ xe dựng làm việc cuộc thệ
vì bộ tài chính, ra đình thử tử tử tiên trên cơ sở cân đối mồn lực,
nghiên cứu cơ trẻ chính sách phu hợp,
để huy động bố nử tư ngoài nhân xanh nhắn hước, chỉnh khai cơ sửa an.
Hó thu tử tử tử trực cũng xa bộ xe dựng đốc hạn nội thành phố chim mêng
cần thơ lạng sân, ca bằng tuyên quan vụ thật,
hình hoả lâm đồng đồng ngày đồng thác an sang,
thành chương cối kỹ nghệ tổng hợp để sất phương an đồng tư cuộc thệ
chính thủ tử nửa an chức ngày hai mai thằng sống.